La primera cosa que se va cuando
estoy nerviosa es el castellano.
(Risas)
Así que, a ver.
Por mi procedencia, realidad social
y étnica de donde nací
siempre he pensado sobre la clasificación
de colores asociada a la raza:
rojo, blanco, negro y amarillo.
Una reducción de algo que
para mí era mucho más rico.
Esta es mi familia,
con miembros adoptivos incluídos.
Llevo en la sangre,
o por lo menos en mi retina,
los distintos colores que forman
la población brasileña.
Dentro de ellos,
nunca me he sentido diferente.
Pero, fuera de mi familia,
algunas veces sí.
Para eso, me he planteado
hacer un catálogo de colores,
pero de colores reales.
Para eso, intenté buscar un medio inocuo.
Algo que fuese
un sistema técnico industrial,
donde un color no tuviera
más importancia que otro.
Por eso elegí las escalas Pantone,
porque los colores primarios
tienen la misma importancia
que los colores mezclados.
Las fotos de este inventario cromático
se hacen de una manera
muy sencilla y fácil de repetir.
En fondo blanco.
En los retratos con fondo blanco
siempre cojo un cuadrarito
de 11 x 11 píxeles de la nariz.
Es el color que aplico en el fondo
y es del que busco
el correspondiente Pantone.
La elección de la nariz es intencional
porque es la primera parte del cuerpo
que cambia cuando tomamos el sol,
cuando estamos resfriados,
cuando bebemos demasiado...
Así que ni uno mismo tiene un único color.
Como ese chico.
El proyecto desde el principio
está planteado como un proyecto online,
global, con convocatorias públicas.
Absolutamente todos
son bienvenidos en el proyecto,
que ha tenido
muchísima empatía con el público
y al final son nuestras
nuevas identidades.
Son las identidades online.
Este proyecto que empezó
de una manera familiar
y que ha tomado proporciones borgianas,
porque siempre me faltan colores,
al principio lo planteo como un proyecto
que viaje por los cinco continentes.
Lo más curioso de ese gran proyecto
fue la cantidad de trabajos
que han surgido a partir de él.
Un proyecto que está inacabado
pero que genera cosas mientras tanto.
Uno es Kyle Mathewson,
que es un profesor de la
Universidad de Illinois,
que usa los retratos de Humanae
para hablar en sus clases
sobre optofisiología.
Este es John Seymour,
John Math Guy, que ha decidido
en el ámbito científico hacer todo
un análisis estadístico sobre los colores
el procentaje que tenía de cada uno,
si había más de un tono que de otro.
Este es un trabajo bellísimo de Emily
Hardin, porque lo que le interesa
es la variedad formal de los
rostros que presento en el trabajo.
Yo publico las fotos en el tumblr,
y ella los dibuja a papel.
Desde Los Ángeles, estamos completamente
conectadas por un trabajo inacabado.
Este es el trabajo de Ana Vasconcelos,
una profesora infantil de São Paulo,
que después de enseñar
el proyecto a sus alumnos,
les da pigmentos para que los mezclen
y después ellos se dibujen.
Es crear esta identidad
personal e intransferible,
y destruir por completo lo que conocemos
como el lápiz de "color carne".
Que no, que ese lápiz
de "color carne", no.
(Aplausos)
Una de las cosas más emotivas
y de las mayores recompensas
y es la vuelta sobre lo
que hablaba de mi familia,
son los emails que yo recibo de
familias adoptivas, de acogida,
sobre este juego hogareño
de cómo identificar esas imágenes
y mirar todos los colores nos iguala.
Esa es la mayor recompensa
de este proyecto.
Esta familia es preciosa.
Y siempre digo que con Humanae
he aprendido a ser un mero catalizador,
yo soy un canal donde las personas
cuentan, en parte, mi historia,
y no dejan de contar las suyas también,
porque ellas cuentan lo que yo digo.
Humanae es como una invitación a presionar
el botón "compartir" de nuestro cerebro
e igualarnos todos a través de matices.
Somos 1076 y espero que
seamos miles y miles y miles.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)